i've been involved with water aid since
around 2016 and and we all went to a few
was went to mozambique in 2017 to
highlight the the problems that that
people in the developing countries have
with the lack of clean water and i
i saw firsthand the the amazing work
that watery do in providing clean water
not just clean water but the resources
and the um
all the things that people need in order
to to maintain and
and have clean water in these
communities and the year after i went
there there was
a big drought in mozambique and then the
year after that there was a flood so
climate change seems to affect the
poorest countries the most and so i
guess this this campaign is about
highlighting the need for funds that the
developing countries need we're asking
for a third of the uk's climate budget
which in total is about 14 billion
pounds so we're asking for around 4
billion pounds of that to go to the
people in the front line the people that
you can see who are highlighting sort of
i guess
represented in these sculptures
people like like them who need the money
the most in order to to help with the um
with the the climate change and the
effects it has in their communities
which is huge tell us that tell us just
a little bit more about about the
sculptures themselves i mean we're
looking at them now that they are
absolutely stunning but they're already
beginning of course to
melt which i suppose is partly the point
yes i guess it kind of highlights the
the the issues the very real issues that
these people have and the fragility of
water they're created by a company
called icebox and they represent the
communities in colombia mali
uh and and india as well and burkina
faso so they're they're beautiful
sculptures and it kind of reminds me of
when i was in mozambique and watching
the women in these communities having to
travel miles in order to get clean water
and the effects that that has in
communities it's kind of a feminist
issue as well if you think about it
because these women are taking out the
communities because they have to spend
most of their time during the day
walking miles and miles and miles to get
clean water and quite often that water
isn't even clean so their children get
sick and it has a huge knock-on effect
so i think that having access to clean
water as a human rights issue
as much as anything else and so you know
this is what watery do they sort of
bring attention to the you know the
issues that these communities face and
how important it is for people all over
the world especially in developing
countries to have access to clean water
so that's what the campaign is about and
also with cop 26 coming up in glasgow in
six weeks time in november we want to
draw attention to to this very um
important uh issue
yeah the the meeting in glasgow becomes
becomes all important on this and a
number of other issues related directly
to climate change but just specifically
on
on clean water can can we put a figure
on it i mean what what what part of the
world what level of what percentage of
the world does not have access to well
you know i mean you and i grew up in a
part of the world
water exists in abundance you know it's
something we a problem we've never had
to deal with
yeah in scotland we have too much water
of anything but and i think about ten
percent of the world face very real
issues with lack of clean water and so
that's a huge amount of people all over
the world so it's something that it
won't go away and especially now with
climate change
having a massive effect all over the
world with droughts and with floods and
with natural disasters that are
happening i mean our own country in
europe has seen the effects of climate
change and in north america as well so i
think it's taken these uh
massive sort of natural disasters to to
come to the floor in order for us to sit
up and take notice um
i think we've already kind of gone past
the point where climate change is uh
you know we we
there is a huge effect on the world uh
from climate change but we really have
to do something about it now it's that
we don't have any more time to waste and
having access to clean water is part of
that that issue
it does feel degree that this has been a
problem that that we have been
discussing you know as a nation as a the
western hemisphere for for decades now i
mean i remember writing an essay when i
was back at school about the lack of
clean water and the problems that led to
with river blindness i mean what hope is
that if cop 26 doesn't get a handle on
this that we can never get a handle on
the problem
i think we have to appreciate the work
that the government has done and the
amount of money they have pledged for uh
climate uh problems issues that we have
which is 14 billion pounds and we're
asking for four billion pounds of that
to go towards the people who are really
um affected by it first hand but we just
have to keep on campaigning you can
never give up you have to keep going
forward you know and if it takes
um
you know
moments like this to highlight the
issues of climate change
these wonderful ice sculptures to show
the fragility of water and to you know
to keep on going on trips with people
like watery to bring attention to
the issues that these people uh have
it's tragic you know and i've been i've
been there i see i've seen the effects
of people who have no access to clean
water and i've seen uh how uh having
access to clean water can make a massive
difference to to people's lives it's
like
you know the difference between having a
color television and black and white
television everything is just
transformed and it's it's extraordinary
um to see what you know raising money
can do for these communities so if
people want to
to contribute they can and get involved
with water aids campaign
um well we wish you and indeed
waterheads very well with the campaign
those statues down on the south bank
just next to city hall if you want to go
and see it at tucker scott lovely to see
you thanks for joining us
thank you pleasure thank you very much